Non
[Musique]
donc ces gens n'ont pas pris de repas
chaleureux que nous les avons vus errer et
nous lui avons dit voulez-vous manger
alors j'ai dit oui et nous l'avons fait
encore un peu de pâtes et nous avons
partagé
[Musique]
qui peut et qui s'en fout alors
inspiré par lui nous mettons
nous avons vu d'une certaine manière
et vivant et vécu
forme anonyme parce que c'est l'amour
de solidarité
un sursis
[Musique]
je nous ai commencé à mettre un morceau de
pain un sac de pâtes et tomates pelées e
en quelques heures, le panier était
complètement plein j'étais
une émotion pour nous
Oui Non
[Musique]
tous les frais la viabilité juste au dessus
que le gaz ne peut pas sortir tout
a la maison
ou de petites choses à faire si je dois dire
que le fait que les supermarchés fassent
permettent de se démarquer la rangée étant un
bénévole c'est super
facilitation pourquoi évidemment pas
ariacorte plus de conseils
[Musique]
naples une grande ville
ville qui a une grande capacité de
résilience et souffrance en ville
solidaire et est une ville qui en quelques instants
de difficulté parvient à donner le meilleur de
soi en tant qu'individus et comment
communauté
il y a aussi un dicton napolitain napolitain
il semble sik sik amer sombre il y a le
Napolitain au pouvoir comme il a à dire
existe vraiment depuis longtemps
[Musique]
le gouvernement doit comprendre quoi dire
évidemment mis en place immédiatement col
soutien de l'europe aussi une économie
de guerre
sinon il y a l'effondrement du sans
revenus s'ils n'ont pas un revenu de
quarantaine ou urgence
mais il faut être rapide et efficace
concret parce qu'ils sont très rapides
efficaces et concrets même les criminels qui
ils ont de l'argent, ils n'ont pas de bureaucratie et ils savent
devoir frapper à la hâte s'ils arrivent
plus tôt ils risquent d'avancer sur la contagion
criminel à naples comme numérique
[Musique]